hey guys happy friday of color it's
actually no longer friday of color it is
friday of color weekend
and now is the best time to subscribe to
the daily wire if you get a daily wire
membership right now you will get our
greatest deal ever to mind certainly the
greatest deal of the year i think
greatest deal we've ever done 50
off 5-0 if you use code dw50
and i'm not going to beat around the
bush here
we need your help we need you
this past year at daily wire has been
the best year the most productive year
that we have ever had
we did so much i probably won't even be
able to remember everything that we did
we launched a movie company we
uncanceled actors that mainstream
hollywood was canceling like disney was
trying to cancel gina carano we said
gina carano is great we're going to
bring her in we're going to do a movie
it's not going to be politically correct
and if you don't like it hollywood you
can go pound sand
joe biden came in and demanded that we
all take the fouchyauchi and he used
osha and all these unconstitutional
means to do it well because of you
because of your support we were able to
sue the biden administration we're the
lead plaintiff taking on the biden
administration right now in the sixth
circuit court of appeals and we're going
to take this fight all the way up to the
highest court in the land if we need to
and it's looking really good and we can
do that so these things don't come cheap
we can do that because of you and
because of your memberships
what about virginia virginia this is
probably my favorite thing we did all
year
we i don't i don't wanna
we may have helped flip virginia red
because
because virginia is a democrat
commonwealth and they've got a huge
electoral advantage there and then our
investigative journalist luke rosiak
went in and broke a major story about a
transgender bathroom that
probably did more than anything else to
flip that that state or that
commonwealth
now we didn't do it because it was some
political operation and we were going to
go in and you know use all these crooked
no
we covered a story
that the legacy media didn't want to
cover
and unfortunately because investigative
journalism is expensive
we we usually rely on the new york times
or the washington post or any of these
left-wing outlets they do the
investigative reporting they have a
bunch of bias in their in their
reporting of it and then we go in we
take the bias out and we react to it but
what about the stories that they don't
want to cover what about the stories
like
like the transgender bathroom and the
horrible crime that took place in one of
them in loudoun county what about those
how many more of those stories are there
out there so it's been the greatest year
ever and it's been the most expensive
year ever okay and if you want to be in
the fight and we love we love being in
the fight and we can only do it with you
we need you to join okay that is
dailywire.com
use code dw50 there are all sorts of
kind of membership perks and you know
you can hang out with us in all access
and hang out with ben shapiro and
candace owens and matt walsh and his
sweet baby gang and drew clavin and
jeremy the god king boring and yours
truly and all that stuff
but
that's like the cherry on top okay
that's just the little
just a little the real the real stuff
for for my money and really for your
money is uh is going out there and
really engaging in the fight and and
breaking the rules and doing things that
that the libs don't want us to do
whether that's in movies whether that's
in the courts whether that's right there
at the ballot box so thank you
for your support we thank everyone who
has helped us out so far take advantage
of this great
once a year if not once in a lifetime
opportunity 50 off a daily wire
membership with code dw50
get that at dailywire.com right now
thank you for your support and we will
see you out there on the battlefield